so many people are stuck in their
startup fees of their business and I'd
love any kind of advice that you have
that can help people like bridge that
gap between that startup phase and then
that next level where you get to start
building a team and start expanding and
growing what do I see to people that are
in that phase enjoy it because you'll
look back on it as your favorite time I
mean vener X is 2 000 people right now
doing hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue and if I could get into a time
machine and go back to Columbus Circle
and be in buddy media's conference room
with Dave Zhang and Marcus krzastic and
AJ and Sam Taggart and just trying to
figure it the out with the dirt and
no Revenue I would do it like this